what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and
Kenyon Martin had this really really
cool question because I was going
through the comments for the Thanos
Buster the famous Buster idea for for
Ironman if those you guys who don't know
I usually read comments for about the
first hour of a video and then after
that I just go off and start making
other videos or I just kind of wander
off and watch TV or something like that
but I usually watch them for the first
hour and and Kenya Martin had this
really cool question so Gideon asked why
not have the characters like switch out
so you have like you know Ironman using
Thor Tech and different things like that
you know and so on and so forth and it
kind of got me thinking from Thor
Ragnarok we know that as guards been
destroyed basically it's like the whole
city of Asgard has been totally
obliterated but here's a funny thing for
the non comic book reader Asgard can be
a little bit confusing so Asgard is both
a city as well as an actual realm so
it's it's very similar to like New York
City New York right like you could take
New York City and move it to Texas and
it would still be New York City if you
wanted to call it that but then you also
still have New York State and so because
of that like like Asgard is it's kind of
a cool situation because it's been
destroyed like a Marvel Comics it's been
totally obliterated before and the whole
idea with this is is my thought process
is Iron Man could rebuild Asgard and and
really like even like the return of
Asgard could happen in a couple of
different ways so so here's how this
whole thing works and I didn't I didn't
misspeak I said Iron Man could rebuild
Asgard that's not an error like you guys
will find out why here in a second so in
with the destruction of Asgard this was
the culmination of something like a 9 or
10 year plan by editor-in-chief Joe
Quesada and the idea was that Marvel he
come out of like the 1990s comic bust
and people were just like ok we have to
like rebuild Marvel Comics in the ground
up basically we have to give people a
reason to give a damn about our
characters because really like
everything was struggling from Marvel
like in the 1990s like it like Fantastic
Four Avengers even the x-men buy the
mother early 2000s I mean like
everything was struggling across the
board because a lot of the writers had
bailed out they've gone on to form like
image comics and there were all these
different things that were going on and
the stories just weren't that great and
so when Joe Quesada came on he brought
on guys like Brian Michael Bendis and
like this whole era of like new talent
that was being that was that was
entering the the Marvel landscape and
one of the things that he did is he sat
down and he kind of formed like this
10-year plan that's kind of 10-year
revolutionary plan to basically revamp
Marvel in its entirety
and a lot of things came out of that you
know for example like the Avengers
disassembled that was actually a prelude
to the events of Houston in which we'll
talk about here in a second but Avengers
disassembled was basically a story with
a Scarlet Witch believed that she had
kids and and that the Avengers had taken
her kids away from her
Marvel's really kind of done crazy thing
with her with her kids like at one point
they were the shards of like a demon
called Mephisto who's Marvel's version
of Satan and then it turned out they
were real we're gonna turn about they
actually weren't real and then they were
the whole time and like it gets it gets
really weird and wonky when it comes to
the kids and Scarlet Witch envision how
they had kids I have no idea I only oh
you know like visions a robot man so
maybe he really is like the total
package I have no idea who the fact
remains here that when it comes to the
that whole Avengers disassembled she
basically waged a war against the
Avengers team and it was crazy I mean it
was she was like a one-woman army it was
nuts she used her powers while Iron Man
was speaking in front of the United
Nations I think it was to basically make
it appear like he was drunk which meant
that like start like like the shares of
Stark Stark Enterprises just tanked
people just like investors were just
selling out left and right and so
because he was losing so much money he
was barely keeping his keeping his
company afloat and he couldn't bankroll
the Avengers anymore and because the
Avengers didn't have any financing they
couldn't function as a team anymore so
like they all basically broke up but
then it was a slew of other things like
it was it was crazy stuff like like
Hawkeye dies uh Jeremy Renner I'm sorry
man I love you as Hawkeye but in the
comics you're not that interesting like
you're more interesting in the movies
than you are in the comics Jeremy Renner
is amazing and the comics Hawkeye died
and it was almost kind of laughable like
The Scarlet Witch basically uses her
reality-warping powers and manifests
this entire Kree are Motta above
Avengers mansion and like soldiers come
down like the whole nine yards it just
like wrecking everything and I want to
say she does something and it sends
she-hulk into a tailspin and she just
goes savage and just just goes
absolutely ballistic but during the
assault on avengers mansion like every
avenge like anyone who's ever been an
avenger shows up they have this huge
like two-page splash screen worse like
every avenger ever is there except for
the ones who are dead and like any
assault i want to say that one of
Hawkeye's exploding arrows is damaged or
something like that and it's gonna blow
up so he's like not like
he grabs one of the Kree soldiers and
takes off into the ship and it blows up
and I laughed a little bit when I saw it
but but still like it is it was kind of
a cool thing but that goes into the
events of house of M where it's
basically like Charles Xavier and
Magneto
and all these guys cuz Scarlet Witch is
Magneto's daughter in the comics they
they sit down like okay
this chicks going crazy and we have to
find a way to like keep her in check and
so what is up happening is like Charles
Xavier calls a meeting of the Avengers
the x-men and I think some miscellaneous
heroes and they all show up on the
mutant island of Genosha which at one
point was like a safe haven for mutants
in in the Marvel Universe and Xavier is
like we don't have a choice we have to
kill Scarlet Witch and like Captain
America is like are you crazy man
we don't just kill people we have to
find a way to treat her and Xavier is
like I'm the foremost authority on Minds
hers is broken she's gonna do something
she's gonna snap and things are gonna go
crazy well then like while they're all
having this debate
Xavier vanishes and they all go on the
hunt for Xavier and while they're
hunting for him they all start
disappearing and then you end up finding
out like like what had happened was like
Quicksilver had gone to Scarlet Witch
and was like you can use your powers to
make everything perfect and so she ended
up warping reality and basically created
a new universe where everybody had
everything they wanted and ultimately
confronted her they were like hey look
you gotta fix this you know once they
realized what was going on and so like
magneto goes crazy because Quicksilver
was the one that got scarlet wish to do
it and magneto kills his son like you do
it's not dude it's the coolest thing
there's this amazing point in the story
when like magneto like dude this guy
this guy come dude it's like he's like
straight out of Crystal Lake like he's
Jason he just comes walking out and he's
like what have you done in my name boy
and like his like Quicksilver starts
freaking out and he was like you didn't
give us a choice you know he's like
every angsty teenager ever where he's
just like so angry at the world but no
one knows or cares why and so he's just
like like he's freaking out and like
magneto just loses it and just like
kills him and Scarlet Witch is like
resurrection from the dead and she was
like she's like you're you're so screwed
up magneto like you're a terrible father
you know you would let me drive the car
like she's that she's freaking out and
goes ballistic and so there's she's like
fine she's like I'll set things back and
so like she returns things and right
before things go back to normal she says
no more mutants and strips 98% of the
mutant population of their powers so
everything goes back to normal and
there's only at least
were aware 198 mutants left and it's
crazy like it's Isha's bonkers stuff but
that was joka saunas way of like toning
down and basically reducing the mutant
population and so then you had events
like Spider Man one more day which
Spider Man fans still can't get past for
reasons I don't understand and and the
whole thing is they're like okay you
know Peter Parker is hard to tell
stories about him when he's married
because it basically puts and puts an
age on it like it dates him and so the
idea of casada was get rid of the
marriage and spider-man fans still can't
let that go so ultimately the marriage
went away and then you basically went
forward with Peter Parker as we know him
now and Marvel said repeatedly Peter
Parker and Mary Jane Watson are never
gonna get married again but it was a lot
of these big changes that had gone on
but this was the process of going
through and just kind of reshuffling the
board and changing things up and so
after Avengers disassembled you got a
new title called New Avengers which was
a whole new Avengers roster like Spider
Man Wolverine Iron Man Captain America a
handful of others it was pretty cool for
what it was the purple man came back in
the first story arc which was amazeballs
new purple man what do was it was
amazing it was it was pretty awesome
a purple man in the show I think is more
interesting than II as in the comics but
I digress terribly so because of this
what you ended up having is you had a
whole host of events that went on like
you had to Civil War you had Secret
Invasion you had fear itself you had a
lot of these stories that were taking
place around that time the most really
like the three most important and the
ones that like to set the stage for this
whole idea of Asgard and everything some
eight minutes into this video is what
you had is you had Civil War you had
Secret Invasion and then you had dark
rain so Civil Wars most everybody knows
is the super heroes Civil War where they
all fight each other over superhuman
registration at the end of Civil War the
bad guys when basically registration
goes through and superheroes have to
register with their identities their
powers the whole nine yards with the
federal government following that came a
story called Secret Invasion and what
you learned was that the scroll race a
shape-shifting race of aliens had been
systematically replacing humans and
superheroes and when everybody found out
about it it led to like this massive war
and so at the end of Secret Invasion
what happened was the Green Goblin
Norman Osborn had intersected
information that would have won the war
and he used that information and did win
the war and so the result was that the
federal government
down and they said the fact that shield
didn't know about this under the
direction of Tony Stark as the director
of shield
he's completely inept so they fire Tony
Stark and they replaced him with the
Green Goblin and because the Green
Goblin is a villain he does what
villains do and so he basically
disassembles shield in its entirety
replaces it with hammer and then starts
this huge campaign to basically conquer
North America and so when this happens
like a whole bunch of things take place
but it all happens under the branding of
Dark Reign in the sense that dark
Wayne's not really a spore a percent
like Dark Reign parts one two and three
and four it's a way to shuffle things
around all the Avengers basically went
underground the x-men left the United
States took up residence in Utopia which
is an island off the coast of San
Francisco all kinds of things were going
on in this Oh what you had is you
basically had Asgard that existed in
Broxton Oklahoma and the reason why was
because prior to the events of civil war
Thor was had basically died like at the
time the story was written he was dead
like he was gone and out of the picture
and that was the end of him
what is up happening is during the
events of civil war Tony Stark clones
Thor and they literally call it Ragnarok
and so this clone goes crazy it goes
awry kills like Goliath who's part of
the superhero community and they end up
shutting it down and then they fix it
and they bring it back but the whole
thing was after the events of Civil War
was were over Thor basically returned
and he traveled he basically rebuilt as
guard in Broxton Oklahoma he travelled
around the world
discovering the essences of the
Asgardian spirits in human form
releasing them and then bringing the
Asgardians back but when he shows up
Iron Man's like hey man like like you
have to yes or register like he'd really
need to register here because I'm the
director of shield and you can't tell me
what to do anymore
dude what follows like in this
conversation between Thor and Iron Man
what follows and part my language here
is one of the greatest ass-kickings in
the history of comics all dudas it's
amazing it's the funniest thing ever
yeah cuz Iron Man's like men dude you
can't tell me what to do for like I know
Chris Hemsworth have you ever seen this
video made out man I really hope they do
this in the MCU Iron Man's like dude you
can't tell me what to do Thor like I'm
the director of shield
I've got the full might of like
America's military force in my disposal
and Thor's like don't give a damn and
like just wrexham just absolutely
destroys them with his hammer it's not
even a fight it's more like Thor
pounding on iron man like a side of beef
until he gets tired and like he's
talking like the bad
trash talk ever he's like he's like look
man like like you may have your little
suit and that's cool but that's all you
are you're a man in a metal suit I'm a
god and it's like it's it's like it's
the beastliest thing it's the it's the
coolest thing ever
and so at the end of it iron man's like
yeah man uh you have helped me to
understand the error of my ways we can
find a resolution here but that's one of
the ways that they could redo Asgard is
basically half Thor rebuild it in
Broxton Oklahoma I personally don't
really think they'll go that route I
don't really think they'll do that um or
at least I don't really want to see them
do that what I want to see them do is
have Iron Man rebuild a house code and
the reason for this is because as part
of that Dark Reign branding initiative
when Norman Osborn was trying to conquer
the United States you had a story called
siege on Asgard which is one of the
coolest stories ever what had happened
is Norman Osborn had looked at Asgard
and realized there was all this magic
and all this power that was there I mean
all the various weapons that were
available at their disposal in the whole
nine yards it was all pretty cool and it
was easy for them to you know they could
access it attainment and then use it for
their own ends so like further their
campaigns and so Norman Osborn alongside
the Dark Avengers traveled to Asgard and
invaded it and literally launched an
attack against it
Thor wasn't there at the time because he
was travelling around the rest of the
world finding the Asgardian essences and
so on and so forth he shows up like
halfway through the battle but what is
it going on here is you have like a
whole bunch of things that go that go
nuts like Loki dies you know and it's
just it's crazy stuff you know but then
you have Robert Reynolds this century
who just like destroys a squad I'm
pretty sure it's Robert Reynolds who
like like just levels all of the Asgard
and it's just like damn you know it goes
bonkers like it goes absolutely crazy
but from there um following the events
of siege on Asgard and really like the
conclusion of the whole Dark Reign
branding initiative this use you know
ten year long error I guess you know
epic by by a joke it's hard to revamp
Marvel you go into what's called the
heroic age and that happened around 2010
2011 and it was really just like the
heroes was rediscovering what it means
to be a hero and you know that kind of
good stuff you know they're like we lost
our way with civil war and so what
happens is iron man peers up with Thor
and rebuilds Asgard but instead of it
being a scarred it's just called as
Gardea and so what you basically have in
Marvel at least from that point running
all the way up until now is you have to
Asgard's you have
was called old Asgard which is the
Asgard that was destroyed during siege
that was teleported to the Asgardian
dimension by Odin and then you have as
Gardea which is a rebuilt version of
Asgard using stark tech that initially
orbited the moon and I think now it
orbits Saturn but that I think will be
kind of cool to see to see like you know
the aftermath whether it's you know at
the end of Avengers 4 that seems more
like a phase four kind of thing you know
like if Asgard you know if they decide
to rebuild it um it's it would seem like
with everything going on it would be
very out of place for your fur
you know Thor to be like hold on wait
everybody wait everybody you know I know
the universe is going upon but I really
want to rebuild Asgard so I'll be over
here while that's happening like like I
have a hard time believing that's gonna
happen I mean you know it's it's
definitely gonna go from like a story
into a conflict and so this seems more
like a face for or an Avengers for
aftermath kind of thing uh but you know
having you having Tony Stark pair up
with Thor rebuild Asgard using stark
tech and then either keep it on earth
send it out or you know over you know
near the moon or something like that I
think works and I think it actually has
a pretty cool effect but again it's just
kind of a theory that I'm that I'm just
sort of throwing out here with the MCU
you don't know what direction they're
gonna go in if they're gonna adapt from
the accomplishment we know that they're
not trying to retell the comics in film
form which I'm glad they're not because
if they did I would be like this is
boring cuz I already know what happens
here it's cool to see it in a film but I
wouldn't nearly be as interested in the
MCU if they just retold comic book
stories that I've already read and so
with them kind of shifting things up a
little bit and changing things around it
is cool and it really does work pretty
effectively so anyway there's kind of my
theory that I'm throwing out here and
I'm curious what you guys think you know
the idea of Ironman rebuilding Asgard do
you think it's something that would be
kind of cool or do you think it's a
little too far-fetched because I also
admit it might be a little too
far-fetched to have have Ironman rebuild
Asgard using stark tech I don't know I
mean I think it'd be kind of a cool idea
but if you're new here to comments
explain it make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you